please read a little boy there's a back
line booty there's a ball you're gonna
face to see you fight people to
understand like explain these jungle
roll-on seal G is so niche compared to
other jungle roles and other teams where
he has to face such a certain style to
aid his team in every way but yeah
watching him like I learned a lot
watching a smithy replays because it's
just he wards for one side of the map
while also farming and while also
pressuring and other side of the map
footages it looks really cool CLG is
veteran jungler xmithie has swapped with
dar doc filling the jungler position on
immortals so in honor of his career on
CLG we compiled some of his best moments
gonna catch a busy Q gets cancelled and
goes link dota is about to die but maybe
listen to say about the fight he's gonna
win a 4 B 5 there just cleaning up kills
now Kali trolls the only man alive
that's how far steel cheese ahead even
me double ad but that means they have to
go my god this is a difficult decision
for CLG in fact should not get that far
oh my god what does it happen he told
the hitter Missy here comes the cloud
the TP what a box they can't really
follow up Chris here
he gets absolutely taken down fanclub
flash is in the holiday rush is down
which means that blasts them in the
fight to be cooked up here by counter
logic gaming double dip does get taken
down because Smith you know Smitty was
on the side of the jungle he hasn't left
it yet burning down the tree that red
box is going to get on them it's going
to force a flash the teepees already
down for Cali trolls
they'd put a little more hurt myth
easier red buff slow a Zonk maybe
bodyslam flash black really well and
another pill for Dublin holy cow CLG
Tallis oh my gosh what a howling gale I
does not want to get trapped in a tight
corridor with those cc's but Oh read out
like this that's kind of what they want
can't just fight the Callisto like that
she's going to toss you out but hi tries
to go in the back I'll put him on
mistake does that kill did not cancel
out anybody they are going to keep alive
here Alfre Mugen still has some shields
on the backside dlg now august geeky and
cloud 9 continuing to try impress
Biggie's sneaking however could be alive
he gets up last mark of the story from
Zion Spartan to shut him down sixty
Seconds to drop the board on the top now
very slow shall appear for that's a
guy's all beard goes back there they're
going to look for the turning cancel him
out immediately zone farm exhaust burn
though wow he's going to use oh my God
he's dying sergeant asked to but they
had the peace of mind to throw a few
autos out really good sideswipe here
they're going to come in from behind him
will they answer the flag go fast
otherwise getting us might of the way
I'm going to be able to see him before
they get through cells get soul in Zion
Spartan very lowest smithy flashes still
up yes advantage to make Anglais here
him but he's got to walk them around
does he waste more time now last is now
first 50 not going to hurt you bad
they'll stay for the fight of 5b for as
they start to split off your sin and a1
b1 now with Xfinity that's it not looked
like it was going his way and he has to
back off dyrus now for the peel but he
goes to the front here he cannot call
for that they wanted the last breath
Sion are able to hit it SS stays alive
with the bloodthirster build less boy in
the middle the monsoon goes off but it's
all he's got for the team TSM is now
offer the south
no you go through the wall yes another
kill
coming in for echo Xfinity comes up
that's a triple over the entire fight
and now taking down Team solomid Madison
Square Garden to be your 2015 soros
blitz champion everyone was willing to
improve in our team so I think that's
the main impact that happened to us and
half of it is the coaching staff that we
have like Chris Sony like they did a lot
for us like that I like a lot from what
sue and yet he just got caught there was
no way they're going to win that fight
that fight it's like you love your new
flash kick Charlie in trouble subtitle
file spotters xmithie
good boulonnais on the lease in play
flying for it go down five thousand goes
our goal for fight and he goes Pacific
just right over the waffle truck to get
to focus on anyway and there's how to
die supposed to work for impulse now can
they stay in this fight or do they have
to run it goes back in attack comes
through that's going to be a hit on to
mash dissolution is low a huge knock
ever here's the follow-through that six
it goes in a mix-up one and a couple of
kills still come back as talk to the
picks off the support in the back by the
Hoopoe get another kill from Selma to
four to be here comes another tackle is
that going to be a third for CLG bank
flashes take the javelin maybe take some
downs and a fourth kill yet again GOG
crushing another team they can secure
the Darren because that buys it more
time so it's maybe the time fire of all
time buyers can he do it while he's
there it's a site by baby sandy he
steals it the counter logic gaming is
very much
maybe on the path to victory with the
follow-up fight rate over solo there's
no hard flying in
darshan tp'ed but he wasn't actually
able to get parents he's on in the Nexus
doesn't even matter this city just came
up that big yes it does
step out of the freak I'm slapping you
it was just I'm just watching my art and
zoning out of how good this is cloud 9
push again there's a flash knock of
tempered pain stays for now and high
Goes Down it's a 5 before 15 is still
alive he's game yourself and CLG are
back in with our shot and he's looking
for Jensen but it's only the closes
hearing it's the real ones is next up is
both entire Shawn will not be stuffed
into flash away take a guess 1 oh no the
door shots coming around you turkeys
under Phoenix Phoenix is a huge utility
factor English fight piglet with the
damage the net backward key is getting a
lot of DPS out Matt is helping stay on
his side for the peel and now they've
chosen side CLG pushing from the top
hitting bleeding leans back and pinklet
he's left the fight they're just trying
to keep it there for the time being
lor low doing his damnedest back from Co
G never mind
you're gonna bring us our Aloha Kaufmann
cock-ups app supports go like was gonna
be the next ones Evelyn is gone we all
be elected he eautiful from who d a340
the LG's got control you looking for if
you're gonna flash stuff just a
professor on the phone there that's four
in a row what a team like CLG
Oh Sean yourself delete for the play on
to the parent here's the teleport now
will they go in the Sun comes across our
size in the pit we were damaged an
adventurous but there's not I'm still
alone in this one Solis
who's going to get it is enough to
thrill they got the parents is now can
they run away it's a for alive by
goodness busy with the epic steal
Chrissy's popping up for but co g with
their second straight championship one
there's like got to be are a lot of
doubters like for us it's like we're
trying to do stuff but we're just trying
to get inspiration from like everyone
around us we're trying to get everyone's
impact in the game does get not done the
dragon goes down and secured by a
quickie studies oh my god can you
believe do you have the face it's the LG
look at Gene's play holy crab smithy
alright so they make the call we're
going for the team fight only guys
aren't here are focus on the objective
and there's wake up Don Smith against
the group the ultimate on the dragon to
keep it alive because they take down the
few people who then who he pushes them
off of the lambs of spices Bluebird gets
stuck in the Dragons it look I can't
even move with his ear wall there he's
stuck and they just separate the team
I never down and down the LG counter
logic gaming with the most unlikely
victory the monsoon is being channeled
keeping CLG alive escapees are in the
retreat mahjong continues to chase the
verdict host Baker in place these
ghastly when it goes back with Vicksburg
to get the kill
counter logic gaming are pushing it
Katie back counter logic gaming story
magnificent win for America
I can't the defending world champion and
it's maybe one more time he got the 50
TP baron he kills dude and Baker is
destroyed
thanks for watching if you want more
great content be sure to hit that
subscribe button